Một ngày sau khi kết thúc cố gắng phán hạp nhân giám tiếp giữa Mỹ về yvr. Tại Mousse Cat,
ông Anh, con dày tổng thống Midu Nontram là Director Snow,
cùng đặt phai viên C. Puy Pháp đã tới thông tổn sân bài USS Abraham Lincoln,
đang hoạt động tại Việt Adrop.
Đóng video, giấu bộ tư lạnh Trung Tâm Nhi Công bộ cho thấy phải đoạn Mỹ thông quan tổn
đập cộ bình sĩ và quan sát hoạt động cất cạnh của mấy bài.
Đồng thấy này, chính xác Trung Quốc cảnh bối xin tình thủ tổn sát tăng hiện diễn con sự tại cố vực
xong sông bởi các tính hiểu ruy trí đối thoại ngoại giao,
tổn thống Ninh Trang Tuyên bố có tổn sĩ Mỹ đang trên đường tới Yvr.
và cạnh báo hộ quan nghiêm trọng nếu không đàn đường thở thận hạp nhân.
Với kinh tế Mỹ cũng đã ki sắp lạnh áp thế bộ dung ham là phần cham,
đối với tức khu sa tí đủng sò thương với Yvr.
Đồng thời công bộ khó trường phạm mới, nhằm sết chào xuất khẩu dụng mò của Tây Râm.
Fiat Râm đã giả vòng lần phán tại ông Anh là hơi đồ thích cực,
và cho biết sẵn sản thích lối thoại, sông nhấn mạnh chương trình phòng thuộc và tế lừa không phải là chủ đề đàn phán.
Chào bố cảnh hạbền tưởng suy chi tiếp sốc Nhưng ra tăng xác em lã nhau.
Chỉnh vọng thu hệ bắt đầu tiên tụi đối mặt với nhiều thích tất.